[موسيقى]
يحكى انها كانت وراء الخطيئه الاولى قرنت
في ادبيتهم بالغوايه والاثم والعوره بعضهم
يشكر الاله يوميا لانه لم يخلقه في جسد
انثى وبعضهم يقول ان الرجل هو راس المراه
وبعضهم يعتبرها ناقصه عقل ودين فهل فضل
الخالق الرجال على النساء فعلا ام ان
النظام البطريركي الابوي هو من صنع رجال
الدين وفقهائه وعلمائه
هل تدفع نساء القرن 21 ثمن خطيئه حواء
الاصليه تبعيه وطاعه ام ان اضطهاد النساء
في ميراثهن وزواجهن وطلاقهن وحضانه
اطفالهن ولباسهن وكل هذا العنف الموجه
عليهن لا علاقه له بالدين اصلا النساء
والاديان السماويه في فلك الممنوع على
عن يعني الظلم المحاكم الروحيه المسيحيه
اللي بتحكم بالهجر رغم انه لنقطه كتير
مهمه انه يعني الانجيل الكتاب المقدس
والمسيح العظيم يعني ما فتح ابدا موضوع
الهجر يعني هيدا اجتهادات او فتاوى من
رجال الدين انا كنت مسؤوله عن بنتي
مسؤوليه تامه يعني ما كان صار عمرها ثلاث
سنين ابوها راحه لامريكا ومعرفنا شيء عنه
ابدا وشبه اختفى وما صرف عليها ولا فرنج
وانا مسؤوله عنها
فبتذكر انه مره كنت انا رايحه رحله على
مصر مع نقابه المهندسين
بيتصل فيني مدير الرحله وبيقول لي انه
يعني بعتذر كثير بس طلع انه زوجك عامل لك
منع سفر كلنا بحاله القصه الهجر كان في
هجر
فهو قبل ما يسافر على امريكا كرم اخلاق
منه عمل منع سفر الي ولبنته فانا وقتها
يعني الجرح الحسيته كان فظيع انه يعني كيف
واحد
انه زوج بحاله هاجر او لا وقتها يمكن
بالمره الثانيه كان طلاق بيعمل لي منع سفر
انا بقول الدين لا تظلمني كامراه فقط
ظلمني كام وكانسان
ظلمت
كامراه وكام وكانسان ككيان كبني ادم بني
ادم ربنا خلقنا من الاحكام الدينيه الدين
بالتحديدا بالمحاكم الجعفريه وانطلاقا مش
بس فقط من تجربه شخصيه كي لا نتهم انه نحن
ذاتيين باحكامنا
بناء على مئات وبدون مبالغه مئات الملفات
القضائيه تتعلق بموضوع المراه والحضانه
الاطفال وحضانه الاطفال الظلم يطال المراه
بكيانه بوجودها بالامور تتعلق
بحياتها بمصيره كزوجي بموضوع الاحوال
الشخصيه بموضوع الزواج والطلاق والارث
بموضوع الامومه
بحرمانه من الاطفال بناء على قوانين مجحفه
باليه ظالمه
في فلك الممنوع وموضوعنا اليوم عن النساء
والاديان السماويه ابدا من هنا من باريس
في الاستوديو مع الكاتب ومقدم البرامج
الاخ رشيد اهلا بك اخ رشيد انت
ولدت في بيئه مسلمه ومن ثم غيرت دينك
واعتنقت المسيحيه من خلال معرفتك
بالبيئتين وبادبيات الاديان السماويه
المسماه السماويه بشكل عام هل تعتبر ان
هذه الاديان ظلمت النساء مقارنه بالرجال
انا اعتقد ان الدين السابق كان اكثر ظلما
للمراه واكثر قساوه على المراه وبان
المسيحيه اعطت للمراه مكانه افضل وان
المسيح كان لديه تلميذات مثلا واول واحده
شهدت لقيامتي كانت امراه فالمراه في
المسيحيه اعتقد ان مكانتها افضل من
الاسلام طيب دعنا سات يعني ساستقصي اراء
كل ضيوف ومن ثم نعود الى الن قاش ساذهب
الى بيروت الكاتب والصحفي نصري الصغير
اهلا بك استاذ نصري فيما نناقشه اليوم هل
من العدل ان يقال ان الخالق لا يحب النساء
وهل هناك فعلا يعني
افضليه في للنساء في دين
مقارنه مع دين اخر ام ان هناك ربما
بالنسبه اليك يعني امتداد لهذا الظلم عبر
هذه الاديان السماويه
لابد اولا من تاسيس القاعده التي انطلق
منها في معالجه هذا الموضوع الحساس
المشكله هي في ضروره التمييز ما بين الدين
كنص وما بين التدين كممارسه
الدين بريء من الممارسات في كل الاديان
والمذاهب فاذا النص الديني هو نص ايماني
اما الممارسه فهي نص واقعي على هذا الاساس
يمكن ان ننظر الى ان المسيحيه عندما كان
المسيح كانت المراه على قدر المساواه بل
احيانا كانت تكون اهم من الرجل
والمسيح كان محاطا بالنساء وكان حاضنا لهن
حتى تلك الزانيه حضنها ومن ثم ظهر لها بعد
الصلب وبعد القبر الامر الثاني
ان هذا الحدث الاساسي في الدين المسيحي
وسيرته
اخفي كليا بعدما تولى الرسول بولس
مهمه تدمير العلاقه ما بين المراه كانسان
وما بين الرجل
والكنيسه اتبعت وصايا بولس لا وصايا
المسيح ونفس الشيء تقريبا في الاسلام
الاسلام من يمكنه ان يقول ان محمدا كره
المراه لا بالعكس كان الى جانب المراه
ولكن من ضمن سيروره المجتمعات كان ممكنا
ليس لم يكن ممكنا ان تكون في نفس الموازات
مع الرجل ولكنه انصفها
ويقال عاده ان الاسلام مع تعدد الزوجات
الاسلام في النص القراني لم يكن كذلك
فانكحوا لكم من النساء وان خفتم ان لا
تعدلوا فواحده ولن تعدلوا
عندما
كان يريد ان ينفذ هذا الامر بس
لحظه فان المساله ليست في الدين المساله
هي في الممارسه وليس في العقيده الدينيه
والعقائد الدينيه لا تناقش لانها مسائل
ايمانيه الايمان لا يناقش نحن لا نناقش
اليوم الايمان بالطبع ولنناقش يعني ما
يعتبره الناس مقدس نناقش الممارسات
المبنيه على ربما نصوص يعني ليست الهيه هي
نصوص يعني نقلت الندى المسلمين عن عن
احاديث ولد المسيحيين ايضا عن رسل اتوا من
بعض المسيح وايضا هناك ايضا ديانه
اليهوديه حيث هناك نصوص كثيره تخص النساء
ساذهب الى القاهره
مع استاذه الفقه المقارن وعميده كليه
الدراسات الاسلاميه والعربيه للبنات في
جامعه الازهر السيده سعاد صالح اهلا بك
سيدتي ساسال او ساطرح عليك نفس السؤال
يعني اليوم الاستاذ نصري فصل بينما هو
مقدس طبعا يعني ما هو ايماني وبينما هو
ممارس يعني الامور المتعامل فيها في
الحياه اليوميه لدى
المؤمنين والمؤمنات برايك اليوم هل ظلمت
الاديان السماويه النساء عندما لم تقم
بمساواتهن مع الرجال في الحقوق
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
انا لي تعليق على موضوع ان المراه هي سبب
الخطيئه وهي التي اخرجت ادم من الجنه
هذا كلام خاطئ تماما هذا لا يؤمن به
المسلمون القران الكريم
القران الكريم يقول
فعصى ادم ربه فغوى
لم ينسب ابدا الى حواء
انها صاحبه الخروج من الجنه وعندما كان
ذلك
بوسوسه من الشيطان لادم واغراه على
بالشجره التي بين بين له انها شجره الخلد
فادم هو اولا هو المسؤول وربنا سبحانه
وتعالى طلب منه التوبه فلا بد ان نبرئ
الانثى من هذه الخطيئه في حاجه فالحاجه
التانيه انا بشكر جدا جدا وبقى احيي الاخ
من بيروت لانه منصفا
منصفا وعدلا في كلامي انا عايزه اقول ان
المفهوم الاديان كلها مصدرها واحد وهو
الخالق سبحانه وتعالى
فسواء كانت اليهوديه
المسيحيه الاسلام كلها مصدرها الله سبحانه
وتعالى والله سبحانه وتعالى انزل الاديان
على تدرج مع كل رسول او مع كل نبي حسب
القوم الذين كانوا موجودين في هذا العصر
ثم جاءت الرساله المحمديه
خاتمه لهذه الاديان اذا لا ينبغي ابدا ان
نقول ان الدين المسيحي يقول كذا والاسلام
يقول كذا كل الاديان هي قول الله لن نقارن
في هذه الحلقه نحن سؤالنا واضح ولكن يعني
اليوم انا لم تجيبني على سؤالي سيدتي هل
برايك اليوم المراه
في الاديان السماويه متساويه مع الرجل في
الحقوق
كما طبعا يعني تطرح مسائلها في النصوص
اليوم الموجوده نعم نعم المراه متساويه في
الدين كما قال الاخ من بيروت ولكن التدين
او تطبيق الدين هو الذي جعل الفروق بين
الذكر وبين الانثى اللي بنقول الذكوريه
التطبيق هو الخاطئ وليس الدين ليس له اي
مسؤوليه سنعود الى النقاش للاسف يعني
سنعود الى النقاش بعد قليل يعني اود كنت
فقط ان اعرف وجهه نظرك بالتحديد في هذه
المساله ساتعرف الى ضيفنا الاخير في من
امستردام عبر سكايب ارحب بالباحث والمتخصص
في علم التاريخ والاديان والحضارات
القديمه دكتور خزعل الماجدي اهلا بك دكتور
خزعل علميا وبعيدا عن الايمان طبعا كما
قلنا منذ قليل هل يمكن ان نجزم فنقول ان
النساء اقل شانا من الرجال في التشريع ات
الدينيه والنصوص الموجوده والمتعامل بها
في الشريعه
والامور الحياتيه يعني الامر يبدا ليس من
السماويه
امر يبدا من بدايه ظهور الدين
في حدود
ثمانيه الاف قبل الميلاد ظهرت الديانه
الاولى اللي هي كانت ديانه امويه في العصر
الحجري الحديث وكانت المراه هي سيده
الموقف كانت هي تمثل على انها نظيره لما
يسمى بالاله الام
والتي كانت تعبت الهه الخصم المراه كانت
تنال حقوقها او على الاقل كانت هي سيده
المجتمعات الزراعيه
واصبح النظام يعني اصبح باتريا نظام
ابوي
مركز العائله هو الرجل
والامهات والبنات هم على هامش العائله في
كل شيء حقيقه حتى عندما نشات في هذا العصر
المؤسسه الدينيه كانت ذكوريه مئه بالمئه
لم تكن هناك في البدايه كائنات ثم مثلت
بعض الكائنات والى وازداد شيئا في شيئا
هذه المركزيه الذكوريه وسمي بالانقلاب
الذكوري واصبحت المراه على الهامش تدريجيا
ثم عندما بدانا مع الحضارات الاولى مثل
الحضاره السومريه والمصريه كانت بعض حقوق
المراه موجوده الى حد ما فكانت نسبيا غير
مضطهده ولذلك افضل حال في التاريخ كله هي
المراه المصريه القديمه لا يوجد على
الاطلاق يعني في كل حضارات العالم
باستثناء ما حصل في الغرب حاليا لاني عالي
المراه حتى وصلنا الى العصور الوسيطه او
التاريخ الوسيط فظهرت الديانات التوحيديه
وكان حال المراه في في اليهوديه ثم
المسيحيه ثم الاسلام قد وصل الى ذروه
الاضطهاد وانا لا اخذ الامور فقط على
مستوى كما قسم على مستوى نظري وعقائد
منفصله عن الواقع انا بالنسبه للواقع هو
الاساس ما حصل هو الصحيح اما انه كل ديانه
لها افكار يعني نظريه محلقه ومنزهه هذا
الشيء اخر نحن لا نعتمد الحقيقه في
معاينتنا الانثروبولوجيه لا نعتمد فقط على
الجانب النظري الجانب العملي والجانب
الواقعي هو هو الذي يعطينا صوره حقيقيه
للمراه
كبير جدا وظلت مضطهده الى القرن العشرين
لم يحصل تبدل حقيقي الا بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه عندما قادت مجموعه من
لان شكل الدول تغير وربما لان يعني دور
السلطات الدينيه ايضا تغير في بعض الدول
لم يعد الدين هو الذي يحكم المراه فقط
المجتمع المدني هو الاساس في هذا الموضوع
وقد نالت النساء في الغرب بشكل خاص حقوق
ممتازه في هذا المجال بقيت سائر الشرق الى
اليوم تحت القسوه والظلم
طيب يعني انت اليوم برايك ما جعل وضع
النساء في في دول الغربيه افضل حقوقا هو
انفصال او فصل الدين عن دوله وامر لم يحصل
في دول اخرى طيب سنناقش هذه النقطه ولكن
قبل ذلك ساعود اليك الاخ رشيد عن يعني
فيما يتعلق اليوم بمساله ما اشار له
الاستاذ نصري قال ان هناك حتى ان يعني هذا
الحديث موجود بشكل كبير ان هناك نظره بولس
للنساء في المسيحيه مثلا ونظرت المسيح او
تعاليم المسيح الى اي مدى تصور المسيح
وتصور مدى هذا الامر الصحيح والى اي مدى
اليوم
استطاعت هذه الدول الغربيه اليوم التي
تقول انها دول عالم اول ان تعطي النساء
هذه الحقوق لان الكنيسه ايضا يعني ازيل
دور الكنيسه في الحكم في حكم الدوله
فقدت هذه القوه
لازم نرجع الاسس مع احترامي للاستاذ لكن
اختلف معه كليا في مساله التفريق بين النص
والتصرف فالنصوص تؤدي الى تصرفات مثلا في
الاسلام لا يفلح قوم ولو امرهم امراه الى
حد الان لا نستطيع ان نضع النساء في
المركز الولايه الكبرى اذا هذا مبني على
نص تصرف مبني على نص فما نستطيع ان نفصل
النص عن التصرف هو ليس فقط مساله ايمانيه
هناك نصوص تؤدي الى افعال على ارض الواقع
وفي نفس الوقت هو قال شيء متناقض مثلا قال
نحن لا نتكلم عن النصوص لكن عن الممارسات
لكن النصوص الرسول بولس هي نصوص مقدسه لدى
المسيحيين وليست ممارسه فاذا هذا التناقض
هو الذي خلق المشكله هذه ليست
الاس المشكله الرسول بولس مثل المسيح مثلا
نجد في غلاطها انه قال ليس هناك عبد ولا
حر ذكر ولا انثى جميع الجميع المسيح يسوع
فهو لم يفرق في القيمه بين الرجل والمراه
لكن نحن نتحدث نحن لا نتحدث عن ايمان
الاشخاص نحن نحترم راس المراه وقال قال
كثيره ماذا يعني بالراس والرسول برجي
يتكلم في الاوراق في الاوراق الرسميه لدى
الكثير من النساء في الدول العربيه يكتب
مثلا على
دفتر العائله رب الاسره الرجل رب الاسره
بقيمه المراه لا يضر بقيمه المراه وانا
دخلنا في النقاش
نتحدث عن الاساس هل هناك مساواه النص
الاول في سفر التكوين يتحدث عن مساواه على
صوره الله خلق الانسان ذكرا وانثى خلقهم
على صوره الله فنحن نتحدث عن القيمه ان
المراه ليست اقل في تاريخ المسيحيه كانت
المراه نبيه كانت المراه القاضيه دبوره
كانت المراه الى حد الان الكنيسه تضع
قديسات كثيرات ومريم اكبر
عند المسيحيين فليس هناك احتقار المراه
بالشكل الذي
يريد البعض تصويره لكن خلينا نكون صريحين
لو احيانا انت تضطر للمقارنه لماذا ظهرت
حقوق المراه في الغرب ولم تظهر في الشرق
لماذا الغرب هو يقود لو لم يكن تاثير
الدين المسيحي تاثير الحذر الرومانيه
تاثير الفلسفه اليونانيه على الغرب هو
الذي قاد هذه الموجه التغيير وهناك من
يقول اليوم ان الشرق ما تسميه الشرق تاثر
ايضا بالقوانين التي صدرها الاستعمار الى
تلك الدول والتي كانت تميز ايضا اذا
النساء يعني هناك من يجيب بهذه بهذه الحجه
ايضا دعني اسمع فقط السيده سعاد صالح
واعود اليها الى الى ضيوف الاخرين اتفضل
للسيده سعد كنت تريدين ان تجيبي على شيء
ما تفضلي والله انا بحس كده ان انا كتخصص
يعني ما كانش المفروض ابقى موجوده بينكم
لان انا شايفه الانحياز ولا التعصب لدين
دون دين بقى اخر لا لا مفيش
لا هو لا لا لا لا لا يا صح لا يصح ان
احنا نقول ان الاسلام هو الذي اهدر حقوق
المراه وهو الذي احضر ارسال المراه بالعكس
هذا راي ضيفنا هنا وليس رايي انا يمكنك ان
تجيبي ان اعطيك يعني الفرصه لكي تجيبي لن
نتمنى اراء تفضل ناقشي اتفضلي حضرتك انا
بناقش طفل لما ربنا سبحانه وتعالى يقول
ولقد كرمنا بني ادم
وحملناهم في البر والبحر
ورزقناهم من الطيبات من هم بنو ادم هم
رجال ونساء ولما ربنا سبحانه وتعالى يقول
تعرضنا للامانه على السنوات والارض
والجبال فابين ان يحملنها وحملها لانسان
من هو الانسان رجل وامراه ولكن كما قلت في
الاول ان الرسول الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم حينما جاء في هذا المجتمع الجاهلي
كان مجتمع يقوم على نظام القبائل ونظام
القبائل كان يفضل الرجال على الاناث لانه
يقوم على الحروب بين القبائل ومن هنا كان
وضع المراه في الجاهليه قبل الاسلام
وضعا سيئا جدا
حينما جاء الاسلام جعل المساواه بينهما في
كل خطاب من الايات القرانيه
يا ايها الذين امنوا المشكل اليوم انت
بالنسبه اليك هو بماذا يعني لماذا اليوم
نجد يا سيدتي سيدات ي من اجل حضانه
اطفالهن سيداتنا ضلن من اجل العدل في
الميراث لما لماذا نجد كل هذه الحالات من
الظلم باسم الدين انا قلت حضرتك في الاول
انا قلت لحضرتك في الاول ان هناك سوء
تطبيق سوء تطبيق وللاسف الشديد
سوء تطبيق يعني انا دلوقتي لما الاقي
الميراث المراه كانت محروبه قبل على
الموضوع اتفضل استاذ ناصر اتفضل وجاء
الاسلام وصلت فكرته خليني اكمل زي ما انت
مكملتش
انا لم اقل شيئا بعد تفضل استاذ ناصر هلا
بعطيك الكلمه ست سعاد جاي لعندك رجع لعندك
تفضل استاذ نصري رجعت ان هذا الجدل القائم
حاليا هو ما نسميه الجدل البيزنطي اذا كنا
نريد ان نناقش الموضوع علينا ان نحسم
الامر التالي
ان النص مقدس ويجب ان يبقى كما هو
ان كان في المسيحيه او في الاسلام او في
اليهوديه مع اعتبار ان هناك ديانات سابقه
كانت المراه فيها بمرتبه الالهه وكانت على
افضل ما يرام المشكله الكامله على كل
المستويات العقائديه الدينيه وغير الدينيه
ان النص شيء
والممارسه شيء مختلف ومتعدد ادى الى حروب
بين ابناء الايمان الوعد
نشهد في المسيحيه حروب المائه عام
نشهد ظلما للمراه والرجل والانسان نشهد
الفحش وكل شيء هذا هذا على مستوى الممارسه
لا علاقه له بالانجيل المقدس وكذلك الامر
ما ان توفي الرسول وقبل ان يدفن بدات
المعارك بين مين بين جماعه الحقيقيين
فلذلك هناك نص قراني مقدس لا يمس ولكن
هناك ممارسات نحن مش عم نبحث بالنص النص
ناخذه كما هو من سيطر عليه المشكله اليوم
في السلطه
المؤسسه فيه من فيه من الدعوات للمراه
فيهم من الدعوات للمراه ما يجعلها في
مرتبه متقدمه جدا ولكن الممارسه الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه والعبريه هي ممارسات مضاده
للمراه كليا من دون ان ننسب هذا العطل
الكبير الى النص القراني النص القراني
بريء النص الانجيلي بريء الناس ليسوا
ابرياء وهذا شيء طبيعي
ضرب المراه هل هو نص قراني ام ممارسه ضرب
المراه هو نصف قراني الميراث النصف
الميراث هل هو نصف قراني ام ممارسه هذا
الشيء هذه مغالطه كل هذه الامور ملك
اليمين هل هو نص قراني ام ممارسه فقط ملك
اليمين نصف قراني التعدد في النساء هل هو
نشر قراني ام ممارسه فين الكلام الذي
يقوله هو غلط حتى السيده نسمع احترامي
كبير لها ما ورد في الاسلام من نصوص لا
يساوي المراه هل المراه مساويه للرجل في
الديه هل المراه مساويه للرجل في مساله
نحاول ان نخرج من هذا الجدل لنفهم اكثر
اليوم يعني اليوم هذه النصوص ربما ساضعك
تجيبين ست سعاد ولكن هذه النصوص ربما قد
يفسرها البعض بشكل مختلف عن الاخر تفضلي
تفضلي
ان حضرتك عفوا يعني مديه الاخرين
الميراث اولا
وبساله تولي المراه الولايه العظمى اللي
احنا بنقول لا الولايه للمراه نزلت سوره
القران سوره المجادله بشان امراه تطالب
الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام بحقها من
زوجها نزلت سوره كامله نزل سوره النساء
تشتمل على جميع الاحكام التي تخص المراه
حقوق وواجبات نزلت ايضا سوره مريم سوره
مريم تبين لنا عظمه
القديسه مريم وابنها نزل سوره الطلاق
القران الكريم لم ينحذ ابدا الى ذكر د لان
المراه خلقت من الرجل طب هل النصوص اليوم
هل النصوص هل النصوص اليوم سيدتي
اجيبين على السؤال هل النصوص اليوم حملت
اوجه لدرجه ان ربما هناك تفسيرات يعني
هناك رجال دين يستخدمون هذه النصوص في
تفسيرات تسيء للنساء وللحقوق النساء نعم
يعني انت في افتراضك اليوم
نعم تفضل
اعترف بان هناك تاويل للنصوص من بعض
المتعصبين
المتشددين جميل لماذا يريدون
قيمه المراه طيب وهذا مخالف تماما لشريعه
الاسلام نحن لا ننسى ابدا دور السيده
خديجه التي استقبلت النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
حينما جاء عليه الوحي الاول مره هي هي اول
من اسلموا
الاسلام هي سيده وهي زوجته
واستقبلت الرسول امراه السيده عائشه كان
لها دور في المجتمع طيب دعيني اسال احاديث
الرسول للنساء دعيني اسال في هناك مدارس
نسويه اليوم تدافع عن الدين على اعتبار
على اعتبار ما تتفضلين به ان يعني هناك
تعتيم ربما على هذا الجانب على دور النساء
في الاديان دعيني اسال دكتور خزعل اليوم
دكتور خزعل في هذا النقاش الذي وصفه
الاستاذ ناصر نصري
بالبيزنطي يعني لانه غالبا ما يدفع يعني
البعض الى الدفاع عن دينه اذا حاولنا
الخروج قليلا من هذه الدائره في النقاش
وسالنا اليوم هل المشكله ان من تحكم ربما
بالمؤسسات الدينيه يعني من كان في هذه
الدائره الاكليكيه كما يقال او في وفي
اداره الدين وسلطه الدين كان دائما
رجل يعني كان الرجل الدين هناك رجل دين
اليوم نشهد على دخول النساء شيئا فشيئا
الى مناصب دينيه عليا في الاديان الثلاثه
حخامه داعيه عند المسلمين او امامه ام في
المصلين او حتى عند المسيحيين في
الفاتيكان هناك رتب اعلى ولكنها بدايه هل
غياب النساء هو سبب مباشر في ظلمهن في
امورهن الحياتيه وحقوقهن
هذا النقاش ونقاش منفصل عن الواقع بكل
صراحه الناس يعني الاخوان يتحدثون فقط عن
النصوص وكان يعني البشر غير موجودين احنا
تاريخ من القهر المدمر للمراه كيف يمكن
هذا يعني بدا من من بدايات الحضاره الى
اليوم
يعني كيف يمكن انكار هذا اين هي حقوق
المراه واينما تناله يعني هذا التكريم
النظري ماذا نفعل به بكل صراحه اقول ماذا
نفعل بكل هذا هاي من ناحيه من ناحيه
الثانيه
عدم وجود المراه في المؤسسه الدينيه بسبب
ان جميع المؤسسات الدينيه حتى المؤسسات
الدينيه التي كانت قبل الاسلام وقبل
اليهوديه وقبل المسيحيه كلها ذكوريه
فهي بالتالي هذا الامر طبيعي جدا يعني هذه
القرون الرهيبه التي مرت كلها كانت المراه
على الهامش مقهوره ومدمره ولا حقوق لها
وكل هذا الكلام المعسول النظري لا يقدم
ولا ينفع بكل صراحه اقول سنبقى نردده الى
الاف السنوات القادمه ثم ماذا اين هي
الحقوق الحقيقيه للمراه اين هي حريه
المراه يعني
دوله دوله يعني فاشله النساء فيها قابعات
في البيوت
بالتعليم هذه النتيجه الطبيعيه فيما بعد
انظري بكل الحقيقه كل الذي حصل هو ضد
المراه ب اقول المراه كائن لا يختلف عن
الرجل مطلقا له كل الحقوق وله كل كل ما
يجب ان يناله الرجل لكن الرجل استولى على
المؤسسات الاقتصاديه
والديني عبر التاريخ فهم مش المراه ودمرها
وكانها وليست منجبته يعني نعم يجب ان نكون
واقعي
سيدتي سيده سعاد اليوم قال الدكتور خزعل
شيء مهم جدا ساطرحه عليك
الذي اقوله الدكتور خزعل الذي يقوله
الدكتور خزعل عفوا اتفضل استاذ نصري واعود
اليك
الذي يقول الدكتور خزعل
يؤكد على ما يلي ان هناك نصوصا وان هناك
ممارسات الممارسات بحق المراه في كل
الديانات كانت مهينه للمراه مهما كانت
النصوص لاننا لا نحكم بالنصوص خلينا نقول
النص شيء والممارسه شيء اخر وهذه الممارسه
كما قال الدكتور خزعل هي منذ البدايه
باستثناء الديانات الوثنيه
باستثناء الديانات الوثنيه مليون سنه مثلا
دكتور خزعل نحن نحن لا نسمعك جيدا لانك
عبر سكايب فقد ساعطيك الكلمه لترد دعه
يكمل للاستاذ ناصر اتفضل استاذ نصري
بس بس انه الممارسه الذكوريه مزمنه مثل
قديم الزمان ولذلك ان الذي حصل في التوراه
ان المراه تعوقبت بدل الرجل عن رغم من ان
المراه قالت له ناكل من شجره المعرفه
ممنوع المرى تعرف ولذلك عوقبت
سعاد والموضوع الاساسي انه اذا يرجع للنص
لا يقف وصلت الفكره استاذ ناصر فقط دعني
اعطي الكلمه روحوا
وصلت فكره المشكله في الممارسات اريد ان
اتحدث عن الممارسات النصوص برايك لا فائده
من الحديث في النصوص طيب ست سعاد يعني طرح
الدكتور خزعل متعدده منها ما هو جيد
واحده
مجرم بكل معنى الكلمه
اليوم تحدث الدكتور خزعل عن التكريم
النظري يعني عندما نتحدث اليوم الشخص
المؤمن وهو امر يعني من حقه ان يدافع عن
دينه فيقول انه يعني هذا الدين كرم وهذا
الدين
اعطى الحق ولكن في الممارسه اليوم ما هي
واين تكمن المشكله حضرتك تفضل انا انا
نفسي انا نفسي قلت ان الممارسه تختلف عن
النصوص
مثلا لو سمحتي لو سمحتي الله يخليكي اديني
فرصه ان انا عندي نصوص كثيره جدا لما نبدا
من اول دور الرجل ودور المراه في المجتمع
نلاقي قول الله تعالى في سوره طه بيقول
ايه ربنا
فقلنا يا ادم الخطاب كان لادم ان هذا اللي
هو الشيطان
عدو لك
ولزوجك
اللي هي حي حواء فلا يخرجنكما من الجنه
فتشقى لم يقل فتشقياني
نسب الشقاء الى الرجل وحده ان لك الا تجوع
فيها ولا تضحى وانك لا تصبر فيها ولا تعر
ارجوكي ارجوكي اريد منك فقط لو سمحتي
النصوص اليوم نحن حددنا قلنا النصوص لن
نتحدث بها اليوم ما الذي يجعل الممارسات
مخالفه لما تتفضلين به تقولين النصوص
انصفت اليوم ما المشكله
بقول لحضرتك في تاويل للنصوص ممن تاويل
الذكور من المسؤول عنه في تاويل ذكوري طيب
هل يجب المزيد من النساء حضرتك حضرتك انا
في مصر وصلت الى عميقه كليه وانا امراه
مسلمه
ووصلت الى الرئيس قسم علمي لا يمنع المراه
ابدا يمكن ان تكوني مخفيه في الاسلام
ومفتيه وانا بقوم بدور الافتاء ودور
الدعوه للنساء لان النساء يحتاجون الى
امراه مثلهم تبين لهم احكامهم الخاصه لان
للمراه احكام خاصه غير الرجل وهذه الاحكام
تشعر المراه بالحياه حينما تسال عنها
الرجل زي احكام الحيض والنفاس والاستحاضه
والمباشره وكل هذه الاحكام قبل ذلك يا
سيدتي نتحدث عن امور الها علاقه مباشره
بالمساواه يعني بين الرجل والمراه في
العائله مثلا اليوم لحضانه الاطفال في
الطلب في كل هذه الشؤون نعم تفضلي شوفي
حضرتك شوفي حضرتك
دلوقتي بالنسبه للطلاق الطلاق ده اولا
الاصل فيه انه محظور لكن لا يسمح به ولا
يباح الا في حاله انعدام التوافق بين رجال
يطلقون نسائهم تعسفيه
ويطلقونهم غيابيا يعني وهو يتحججون بالدين
اليوم
ربنا ربنا جعله جعله بيد الرجل لماذا
لان المراه عاطفيه يعني هذا لا يظل ليس
هناك محتوات عاطفيه عاطفيه حينما يحصل اي
خلاف بينه وبين زوجها تقول له انت طالق
طيب انت طالق انت طالق لكن الرجل
بيتحكم في اعصابه
ويعرف انه يقوم بكل هذه الحروف في العالم
[ضحك]
لو سمحتي فقط اتفضلي كملي كملي فكرتك لو
انا هقوم انا هقوم لا لا ابدا
تكلمتي باكبر قدر
اتكلم في موضوع الطلاق وحضرتك هتعطيني
قلتي المراه لا تطلق لانها عاطفيه وصلت
الفكره لا ما وصلتش لا ما اوصتش نحن هنا
نتحدث عن طلاق
لم يهدم حق المراه في الطلاق في حاجه
اسمها الطلاق بناء على الضرر في حاجه
اسمها
ماذا فعل
ممارسات التي تحصل اليوم
ما انا بقول لحضرتك على الطلاق حضرتك بصي
انا اسفه جدا انا ما ليش في المجال بتاعكم
ده وسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يعني انا عندي
خلي الخطا
بقول دلوقتي حضرتك بتقول الصلاه اولا في
الزواج لا يمكن الزوجه لا يمكن المراه
تتزوج من شخص لا تريده
لابد من رضا
واختيار شكرا المراه
مع احترامي لها هي هي تذكر جانب وتتغاضى
عن جوانب كثيره مثلا احنا هنتكلم عن
الممارسه الى بدايه الى بدايه القرن
الماضي الى بدايه القرن الماضي وفي بلدان
الاسلاميه تباع النساء ملك يمين ويشتريها
الواحد ويمارس معها الجنس ويبيعها الواحد
ثاني هل سببه نص قراني هل منعه النص لم
يمنعه النص منعنا الغرب من ممارسه هذا
الامر في بلداننا بنصوص دوليه كل هذه
الامور شهاده المراه نصف شهاده الرجل هذا
نص قراني وممارسه ايضا كل هذه الامور اذا
اذا هذه الامور متعلقه بالممارسه وليست
نصا مقدسا نؤمن به فمجتمعاتنا تعاني من
النص وتبعياته وتعاني ايضا من الممارسه
ما الحل بالنسبه اليك
هل نعمل علمانيه نفصل نفصل الدين عن
الدوله ونعطي للمراه كامل حقوقها هذا هو
مسلسل القوانين عن ما شرعه الدين في هذه
المسائل متفق انت استاذ نصري والله الحلقه
شيقه ولكن غابت عن الموضوع الرئيسي اللي
هو مقام المراه في الديانات مقام المراه
في الديانات له خصوصيته وفق كل دين من
الاجيان انما على مستوى الواقع
النساء المسلمات لا يشبهن ما جاء في
القران والرجال المسلمون لا في القران
وكذلك في المسيحيه وكذلك في اليهوديه فحاج
بقى نقول ان عندنا نص مقدس ولكن بالمقابل
هذا النص المقدس الذي لا يمس مقابله في
عنا مسيره مدنسه تطاوا المراه في
مجتمعاتنا تدعس علي للمراه
يعني بالنسبه اليك اين يكون بدا بعد شرح
ان يجب فصل يجب فصل الدين عن النقاش بما
له علاقه
بالحقوقائع اليوميه والسياسيه التي تعيشها
المجتمعات في مجتمعاتنا المراه ماساه كبرى
عندنا
العمومه ماساه كبرى الرعايه الكبرى
لبنان نحن متقدم والاخرين تعالوا شوفوا
المحاكم الشرعيه والمسيحيه والشيعيه
والسنيه شوفوا الماسه شو هالحكي هذا بقى
انه لا النصر النصوص مقدسه
ولكن الواقع لم يكن كذلك يعني ما فائده
هذه الندوه اذا كانت الامور كلها تمام
يعني بكل صراحه يعني يعني
فعلا فعلا
ولا تتمنى وما
اتفضل اتفضل دكتور كمل نعم انا اعتقد اننا
نغطي عيوننا عن مشاكل مرعبه
في هالمراه مسممه ومدم
ره لا يعقل لا يعقل ان نهمل هذا في يعني
في مشاكل كبيره جدا الحل كما قال الاخ
رشيد هو بالعلمانيه ربما مدنيه وقانون
مدني ينصف المراه هذا هو الحل هذا هو الحل
لا يوجد حل اكثر
لكي لا نقول كلمه كلمه علمانيه لانها تخيف
ست سعاد اليوم برايك الدوله المدنيه
الدوله المدنيه التي تفصل التشريع الديني
عن الحقوق المدنيه للمواطنين هل يمكن ان
تكون حلا من اجل انصاف النساء امام كل هذا
التحكم الذكوري الذي وافقت عليه انت في
امورهن وشؤونهن الدوله المدنيه دي يعني
موضوع سياسي لا علاقه له بالتطبيقات
الدينيه يعني المفروض ان في قانون اسمه
قانون الاحوال الشخصيه
مستوحى الشريعه ولكل دين قانون الاحوال
الشخصيه هذا القانون بينظم الحقوق وال
لكل من الزوجين
والابناء داخل الاسره وانا عايزه انهي بس
محادثتي
بايه بسيطه قوي ولهن مثل الذي عليهن
بالمعروف وللرجال على ان درجه بدا بلاهن
يعني بدا بحقوق المراه قبل حقوق الرجل
ولهن مثل المثليه الذي عليهن اذن الاسلام
كرم المراه شكرا
نتمنى لهن المساواه والنقاش في فلك
الممنوع لا نهايه له ونترك لك ولك حريه
التفكير وحريه الاختيار شاهدونا دائما على
واستمعوا الينا على اثير اذاعه موتكارلو
الدوليه تحياتي
[موسيقى]